Justin how are you going from the
introverted writer to the extroverted
producer where you have to leave the
house you have to be visible and pitch
your idea how do you make that shift in
your mind it's challenging it's it's a
very difficult process I think you know
it's it's not easy it's just something
unfortunately that you have to do in
this industry so you know that being
said I think that as a writer you know
and I'm probably not the only one I wake
up with different excuses not to write
that day I look for any excuse not to
write that day I would rather sometimes
clean the house or you know go grocery
shopping but the house is spotless
literally because I'm cleaning it half
the time instead of writing because it
gets me out of a day of writing because
writing can be so challenging so I think
when you have to put on your producer
hat that usually means you're in a good
position that means that you probably
have worked diligently and and you know
very very hard over a year or more
getting the script where it needs to be
or at least developing the concept and
the idea and you've been getting
positive feedback and so it's time for
you to go out and start pitching in to
the people that need to see it so I
think after the difficulty of of writing
it's just the necessary step so like I
said I mean instead of going and
cleaning the house or getting groceries
or or finding some other excuse the
excuse becomes you have to get out and
network and you have to talk to people
and you have to try to sell this project
and sell the story and sell the script
so it's it's a necessary evil but it has
to be done so I just I think that there
are definitely writers out there they're
much more comfortable at home writing
and not selling it not trying to sell
the script I also think that there are
writers that are much more comfortable
trying to sell a script than actually
writing it so it's just trying to find a
balance if finding you know a writer to
work with as a you know a writing team
where one person is better as a producer
and the other is better
as a writer and joining those together
then that's you know I think more power
to you if you can find that dynamic in
that relationship if you're going to
write a loan you just have to find a way
to balance the two so I when I'm in the
zone and I'm writing as well as I
possibly can
I will not leave my house for weeks and
I will just continue to do that if I am
struggling and I'm not writing that well
then I will leave and if that's the time
to start pitching projects then that's
when I'll pitch those projects so I
think it comes in waves you know you
take the creativity when you can take
the creativity and when that dries up
for a little bit then you take the
business side of it because at the end
of the day it is a business and and
selling your script and selling your
project is of the utmost importance
you